is it a scarf or a Shaw or a pashmina
there's many names for that Garb what is
it it's a scarf it's a scarf you're very
fashionable I think it's your voice your
where's your voice
from I don't know Brazil you don't know
Brazil you were you were like I'll just
it's fine no I'm not I'm not Portuguese
I'm not going to come and invade again
um there always you know there's always
some uncertainty that's why I don't talk
to Indian people in the crowd cuz
they're like [__] he's going to steal
our diamonds another time um that's
lovely may I ask what you do my
Brazilian friend here in New York here
in New York or anywhere it's a global
World Interior Design interior design
you're very [__] stylish I mean the
rest of you you're cool but like
Brazilian cool is better isn't it in New
York you're like I'm cool I wear all
black and over there they're like uh I
wear Shaws and coopa gabana what so
racist um interior design what do you
think of of this look there's a spider
and it's not even Halloween ooh cookie
left field chaa got keeps thinking um
you you live in New York though and you
interior design for private rich people
or just for kind of boring corporate
shills I'm hoping Brazilians know what
the word shill means cuz that was quite
was quite high level
language private rich people private
rich people [__] yes get that paper
and then and are you here with a partner
tonight or is this one of your clients
and you're just like come here and look
we could D drapes which have
Shades yeah you look like you could be a
tech bro really cuz it's that kind of
you know slightly unkempt beard and kind
of sports Tech fleece but you could have
billions of dollars do you unfortunately
not unfortunately not you also Brazilian
you're the least Brazilian looking man
I've ever encountered you cannot see
this man imagine me and then imagine if
I told you I was
Brazilian it's the same experience I'm
having now when I look at this man
you really what's your name fake
Brazilian Mark Mark not Brazilian
he's oh yeah Mark you don't even like
churas skua or whatever is you don't
even you've never even eaten a chicken's
heart have you mark he has he's eatting
many chicken T chicken ts are delicious
aren is this a whole Brazilian row I
mean you El Salvador El Salvador okay I
was going to say there was definitely
some South American Vibes going um look
at mark this isal Central Central I
apologize I again we never owned that
part of the world so I don't Europe I
will tell you where your [__] country
is to the coordinate but South Central
America um Al Salvador what's Al
Salvador known for what' you do down
there Bitcoin now but Bitcoin now so
it's you know it's gone bad
when it's never an economy that's
booming that goes you know what we
should switch to
cryptocurrency see how it goes from
there I mean look I'm from England we're
a failing island nation but at least we
still have you know [__] physical
currency our bank notes are fun at the
moment cuz they still have the dead
Queen's face on and we we've got the new
king and I kind of feel the like well
he's quite old do we really need to
print ones with his face on as well it's
going to take like two years and they're
going to put it out and then you know
when he dies I guarantee you the money
will have Williams face on it
immediately cuz they just got it all in
store like yeah we knew that was
happening you were doing thumbs down you
not a fan of the Royals I'm not a fan of
Charles not a fan of Charles who's your
favorite Diana
Diana okay everyone's watching the crown
that is we love hot ghost Diana spoiler
alert she
dies do you know cuz some of you were
boarded wait is anyone watching the
crown and didn't realize Diana that
would be a br oh my God I can't believe
they killed off the most popular
character you thought Diana is still
alive the least Brazilian Brazilian man
but this is a great night inter what's
your when what's the simple hack for
improving your
space you walk into someone's apartment
and you just go like just [__] boom
like brighter walls to make the space
bigger brighter walls make the space
bigger cool Al Salvador what's your
advice for improving a room or a
country's
economy it's it's quite fun in in my
younger days when I was a single man I
would be very intimidated talking to
pretty ladies now I'm married I've got a
child I don't give a [__] I'm just like
let's offend them let's be rude let's be
rude that's great El salvadorians what
do you do surf you surf that's your
actual vocation that's what don't ask
her questions anymore don't ask her
questions anymore once you've got past
the answer surf it gets
disgusting surf the dark web for child
pornography yes we've Cut Her Off
there okay and then we didn't Mark Mark
the fake Brazilian do you have a
particularly Brazilian job work in
finance you work in finance I [__]
called it mate I called it absolutely
called it when you were a little
Brazilian boy growing up in s Pao s
Paulo what did you want to be was just
there soccer player a soccer player you
stot type that's him
moving really you also
Brazilian you should start up a podcast
called the whitest
Brazilians you're so go make a [__]
little footell team that's brilliant
well okay well let's uh let's um do this
Ethan mate do you want to do you want to
give me some give me some music okay you
what you don't know about me Mark is
growing up as a little boy in the
favellas of Manchester I wanted to be a
freestyle rapper that was my goal and
that's someone who makes up raps based
on the audience and so involving you
guys involving you involving you what's
your name other fake Brazilian Luka Luca
that's how you do it Mark look at
that we got the fake boy but I got the
the truth there he was shouting out Mark
but I spy LCA the real one the thr
Brazilian man over there kind of hard to
see probably got a tan even though it's
winter no mistake he puts the bronzer on
he wants to make it look fake walk
around that's a real Brazilian fell I
see Mary never even seen a for Valery
down in sou poo best believe he gets
burnt to a crisp when he's on the beach
if I gave him a football he's like oh no
tried to kick it but fall over ho ho who
name
who's Ronaldo the old one number nine
yes I tell you working Finance got a
pretty lady she F Brazilian voice do
interior design I walk in make it set
right there you got to paint your walls
much brighter and that way the rooms
more voluminous you say it in Brazilian
and then we do discuss you make the cash
off the rich corporate over there to the
right you deserve it they be like hey
Brazilian girl can we borrow some money
because our country and our Salvador has
done it so funny where are we bed it
came from the mouth you corrected me
when I said South you were like no is
this British guy mental where are we
actually the globe with Central America
everybody best know we're better than
huras or Mexico you know we'd rather say
[__] Guatemala El Salvador yeah you know
we'd rather with the father of
cryptocurrency how's it going really
[__] currently confronting these you
know we really joined we fell for the
whole con of the Bitcoin we were like up
and up do it properly going to be a
world lead in economy we'll be the
biggest ones in the world we'll get what
we deserve and when I've got my pension
yeah I'll Just Surf don't tell him any
more details about that if she says I
like other things rewind it back we got
to take that you know I feel the thrill
there filling chairs in your Long Jacket
that be silver looking ever so fly we
can say this as much as he's not
Brazilian you look like you're in The
Matrix shining with the mirror that is
what we do you would get excited but
then you said oo I don't like Charles
he's a bad King I'm watching the crown
they did a bad thing hit a little wall
in the tunnel and they slam her I was
like I can't believe it cuz I did stand
Diana but then she died but now she's
better the most she'd be coming back
there she be there as a goes I hate
Charles I'll be kicking him until the
Pricks bleeding cuz he betrayed my
girlfriend by
[Music]
[Applause]
cheating
you guys are lovely
H thank you very
much